um i'm really excited to welcome
professor my van tran here today um dr
tran's work on authoritarian politics in
myanmar myanmar
really resonates with so many of the
exciting conversations that are going on
at yale and elsewhere at the
intersection of southeast asian studies
and politics
thanks largely to my colleague jim scott
we have the long-standing interest in
myanmar here at yale and i'm really
delighted to be able to host someone
like dr tran who has recently completed
a phd supervised by our own former phd
student from yale tom popinski who is at
cornell and she completed her phd in
2020.
dr tran's dissertation
is a study of public activism under
repression and she uses historical case
studies from myanmar's pro-democracy
movement during military rule to
understand how pro-democracy movements
operate under military rule
given the recent coup in myanmar and the
return to military rule i think i'm not
alone in wanting to learn more about
what her research has revealed and to
try and fight
in addition to her scholar
doctor
research institutes and critics tech
organizations in myanmar to deliver
insights and policy recommendations on
topics concerning local governance
digital literacy and online
disinformation her recent analysis and
commentaries on burmese politics
appeared on the washington post
brookings institution al jazeera
associated press and so on so please
join me in welcoming dr tran to our
virtual series her talk is entitled
engineering public hostility against
popular movements takmadaw's suppressive
repertoire in urban myanmar
i'll turn it over to you dr trent thanks
thank you so much uh for this uh
generous introduction eric um just to
clarify i'm not a professor i got my
doctorate degree but yeah uh not yet a
professor um but yeah so so first of all
um i just like to
um say thanks like to to also express my
express my gratitude toward um eric as
well as uh toward the council of
southeast asian studies at yale for
inviting me uh for
this occasion for for this opportunity
for for me to share about my
research today
and um and and um yeah and and i think
even though i don't get to be at yale
physically but at the same time it's
still
very nice that here that i still can see
um a few like familiar faces as well as
you know i can still get the attendance
of a lot of the prominent scholars like
in um of course in in vermont studies
here as well so um so uh with that said
i'm very excited um to present my work
and also to to have you know um
hopefully
a a lively discussion um afterwards um
so yeah so so um
uh without fur further ado i i'll just
jump right in uh so regarding the the
the talk today um so um eric has um also
briefly introduced like gave a brief
summary of my dissertation so um this
presentation is uh it is also um it
comes from uh the the dissertation
itself
and and for uh the the talk today uh my
um
uh
my uh my presentation it will focuses on
a particular part of the dissertation
which is on the uh suppressive
repertoire the strategies by the burmese
military the dummado
you know in terms of engineering and
provoking public hostility against the
popular
urban pro-democracy movement
during military rule between 1988 and
2010
um this talk it will proceed um as
follows so first of all i
will um i i will discuss a little bit in
terms of the existing scholarship as
well as the existing um you know
reports and and research um on the
burmese military clintons suppression of
descent
and via this this
brief
review
i would hope to show that most of this
existing studies
on this particular topic they have
focused on analyzing the more
straightforward tools of repression by
the hunter
however
you know there is a gap in terms of the
understanding about
more deceptive strategies to mobilize
public hostility against the protesters
so um therefore
and from there i would proceed to the
second part of the presentation
where i aim to shed light on these
strategies by just opposing two case
studies of popular pro-democracy
protests um one is the foreign uprising
in 1988 and the second is the staff on
revolution um in 2007
and
uh
and you know like
based on the uh uh
my analysis of original qualitative data
um i
hope that this talk if via this talk
i'll be able to show a first of all um
a typology of the military's oppressive
repertoire as well as you know to show
um to the audience today the
various effects of these different
strategy combinations um and before i
end the talk i will also touch briefly
on how the findings from my research
would also have relevant implications uh
for the current situation in post-crew
myanma as well as for the system you
know um
other situations of suppression of the
civic space beyond myanmar as well
so um so first of all what do we know in
terms of the state repression of descent
um in in myanmar um according to
existing
independent reports as well as academic
studies and research
the five decades of military
dictatorship in myanmar were a period of
brutal repression against poor democracy
activism
like from the 1960s to the 1970s
um
to the 19 sorry one second 1980s um up
to the 1990s and throughout the 2000s uh
so during you know like these five
decades we what we have witnessed is
how the military rule
has resulted in
thousands
of
casualties and deaths of the protesters
as well as thousands more arrests
um and these are the very um you know
like um quite um
well cited numbers uh by the reports by
amnesty international as well as reports
by the special rapporteurs on the
situation of human rights in myanmar
in addition
after each of the protest cycle the
burmese military kunta is also known to
have further confined the domestic
opposition movement toward a highly
restricted form of party politics that
the regime could control
um so in here i like um
works by christina fink and join line as
well as the navy
together offer a very informative
description of how the government was
determined to persecute dissidents so
the regime did so by making all of the
dissident activities illegal detaining
thousands of prominent activists and
issuing arrest warrants for other
thousands of activists in exile um and
on top of that only allowing
you know political parties with no
campaigning activities to be legal
and during these five decades although
less well-documented
the regime leaders they have also run
multiple campaigns to vilify the
opposition and mobilize for public
hostility toward protesters
so also with a goal right to quell large
scale descent yet compared to the more
direct tools of repression such as
protest crackdowns arrests and massacres
etc the strategies to provoke public
hostility
are much less analyzed and most of the
literature on this issue so far
um in the myanmar context
only draws from either public propaganda
by the military in uh 1988 or around
1988 or a handful of activist accounts
um of the 1988 protest cycle
um
okay so um for for instance right so um
according to um the work um
uh where uh so according to uh berto
lindner's um depiction of the military
crew that ended the for it uprising um
on september 18 1988
in order to disseminate allegations of
the uprising as harboring criminals
the state
broadcasted
and also labeled any protest
participants as violent delinquents and
such type of intentional framing was
also more blatant later on as the state
also reported about the um
the protesters as quote-unquote
destructive elements
and the junta even announced that most
of the deaths on the september 18 were
caused by
quote looters and other unsavory
elements unquote uh moreover according
to
other studies right
according to a lot of studies we also
have found that after the protest
after the pro-democracy uprising in 1988
the military regime held a series of
military press conferences
accusing the
main opposition party at the time the
national league for democracy nld of
being controlled by the communist party
of burma or foreign forces um
so so most of these types of studies and
reports that we have seen uh the
materials have come from the public
propaganda of um the military
um punta however
um you know we we we do
um have you know have a glance right
like uh the more deceptive strategies uh
via the work by christina fink um where
she uh quoted the experiences of student
activists in 1988 who suspected that
military asians in clean clothes were
trying to provoke them toward committing
violence or murder in order to create a
chaotic situation so that the military
would have a justification for cam
clamping down
um however overall right like um
none of these types of studies or
research and reports have been able to
examine um fully the range of the
various uh strategies um both public as
well as the
covert strategies to provoke um
public hostilities towards the protest
movement and moreover um since um
you know due to the lack of evidence
from the point of view of the um you
know people on the receiving end of
these strategies
namely the protesters and and the
general public themselves like we um
like via this work we also have not been
able to really understand whether these
state strategies these types of
strategies have they really like how how
much have they had an effect
um
so uh therefore um this is the the part
that i would like to contribute with
with my research uh and more
specifically in in order to shed light
on the state leaders accountability in
manufacturing public hostility toward
protest movements i analyzed original
first-hand evidence from two case
studies of popular pro-democracy
protests
as i said before the foreign uprising in
1988 and the second revolution in 2007.
not only are they unlikely cases for the
emergence of civilian hostility toward
the protest movements but they also
experienced two different combinations
of state strategies which i will
describe later on
therefore i find that studying the
public response toward the
peaceful activists in these two cases
will allow me to highlight impacts of
each type of the state repertoire
so so first of all the protest events in
both
1988 and 2007
they are unlikely cases for civilian
disruption and hostility toward the
protesters since these protests were
highly popular and received widespread
approval from the general public and at
the same time the antagonism and
grievances were the military regime was
also
high
so the 4h or 888 uprising witnessed its
first main protest on august 8 1988 and
the uprising was a culmination of a
cycle of student activism in yangon in
the preceding months due to the students
grievances toward general nawain's
one-party dictatorship and from
mid-august onward the
uprising then became
like a festival during which the general
public including factory workers farmers
office staff artists homemakers civil
servants and soldiers throughout the
country turned out in drugs to
demonstrate however almost one month
later the military such a cool and
brutally crack down on the protesters as
i said before on september 18 1988
um later on uh as for the saturn
revolution um this is a you know a
protest cycle that occurred during
september 2007 2007
and it earned its name because it was
led by burmese buddhist monks whose
robes usually have maroon saffron colors
the immediate cause was general
dangerous government sudden reduction in
fuel subsidy that led to large increase
in fuel prices and this brought hardship
on the majority of the population who
lived near or in poverty as a result the
monks they also started to take to the
streets all over the country however 10
days after the start of the main protest
starting on september 26th the security
forces violently cracked down on the
demonstrators
and raided multiple monasteries at night
so consequently all of the saffron
protests stopped
around the end of september
but despite their popularity
both to
1988 and 2007 protest events faced many
incidents where local residents either
stay away from protest events or
actively confronted and blocked protest
marches
and moreover
the military
itself also employ different
combinations of strategies to provoke um
anti-protester hostility and legitimize
depression
so at first
in as you can see in this table here in
both 1988 and 2007 as each protest was
gaining popularity the government did
not crack down right away but started
broadcasting its allegations of
protesters as criminals
the regime avoided using the word
protesters to describe the movement
participants but instead labeling them
as rioters
in order to promote criminal images and
at the same time the state agents they
also
were part of a covert strategy
where they disguised as civilian
observers penetrated the protests and
committed violence towards security
forces as well as towards civilian
targets such as attacking the police and
or destroying public properties
in addition in 1988
in order to manufacture images of
quote-unquote anarchy
which is the word that the regime later
on used to describe the 1988 events so
in order to manufacture these type of
anarchic images that would further sow
distinction between protesters and the
general public and also to justify a
military coup the regime can also
covertly incited peaceful protesters and
dissidents to commit violence against
innocent civilians
so um in order to
further examine you know like the um
different uh methods um of these these
types of strategies as well as to
examine you know like their varied
effects um i would now turn to
describing to you
you know the data that i have collected
as well as the
how i'm planning to analyze them as well
so
during my field work i conducted
in-person semi-structured interviews and
collected written accounts
mostly by yangon residents from diverse
demographic and political backgrounds
and since i try to mirror the
geographical representation of yangon
residents in my sample i can also take
advantage of the largely accidental
exposure and non-exposure to state
strategies among the interviewees in
order to highlight their effects the
strategy's effects on civilian responses
and in order to build trust with
the interviewees while maximizing the
diversity of the samples
of the sample i also worked with private
schools libraries and institutions in
yangon and as well as their affiliates
to recruit respondents
the interview process stopped once my
sample
reached you know like all of the
sampling criteria as you can see in here
regarding you know the demographic as
well as political representation and
when the data also reached um saturation
um which means you know when the new
integrated new interview data was mostly
redundant and also offered to a little
new information
for the written accounts
i collaborated with the same
institutions to identify and collect
published
autobiographies memoirs and interviews
by former activists
during you know these two decades
between 1988 and 2010 as well
so
with these graphs here you can also
basically take a glance at the
uh distribution um of the different
types of demographics like um among the
respondents and among the
people where who's who's written
accounts that i have collected here
um right so based on these data um
when i um
based on my analysis of these types of
data
what have i found
um so first of all regarding the state
strategies to frame protesters for
violence um
during both the 1988 and
2007 events many interviewees recalled
how the government spread news through
mass media that rioters hid among monks
and laymen demonstrators in order to rob
properties poison food and water
burn down cars and destroy traffic
lights offices and households
by broadcasting about multiple communal
unrest across different townships in
yangon the authorities wanted to make
the public perceive an immediate threat
from
quote-unquote subatours mixing among
protesters and these types of news reach
many neighborhoods and as a result most
of my interviewees heard these rumors
even though they did not actually might
not have
actually witnessed the alleged sabotage
right
so this is one
example here
and at the same time in 1988
the regime also shut down government
offices for weeks and also blamed the
protesters for the shutdown charging
them with vandalizing these offices
so
in the next quote here what you'll find
is that this is a former civil servant
who recalls how she received a news
quote-unquote news about her office's
destruction um in advance
yeah and
secondly
uh in order to
further produce um the optical illusions
of protesters as criminals the state
they use their own agents to infiltrate
peaceful protest and instigate riots
in 1988 the state agents committed
arsons and carry out robberies in
different townships so as to make local
residents believe in their allegations
and in 2007
these asians
also attacked the security forces with
bricks and rocks so that the military
could use this as a justification for
soldiers to shoot protesters later on
and as you can see from these quotes
here
multiple protest participants and
observers
have detailed these types of accounts as
well
right
um but
not stopping there right so um at the
height um of the um for eight uprising
uh the
the state itself was also involved in
inciting protesters toward committing
violence toward
civilians
so what happened
um at the height of the void of rising
the states they
had
they released prisoners and also have
these prisoners poison the public water
sources that the protesters drank and
on top of that they also hired people to
attack these activists as well and
multiple residents in yangon witnessed
these attempts
however as the rangoon
general strike committee at the time was
worried about the government scheme to
frame the people's uprising
as chaotic and as anarchic they released
a public statement requesting people not
to harm and not to kill the alleged
criminals
uh former student activists in yangon in
1988 likewise here also recall how they
were involved in detaining the alleged
criminals but did not condone killing
them
and um in another example
um you know provided by the written
accounts by
a
strike committee member um himself um
after his strike committee caught a monk
with three jingles which were um
homemade um weapons um the the the
committee just interrogated this monk
confiscated the jingly and then let the
monk go
um so
overall right the
the general strike committee at that
time they also tried very hard to make
sure that they could control these
different protesters and strike groups
and strike committees
so as to make sure that they are uh you
know do not
commit
violence against innocent civilians
therefore according to
many activists and observers in 1988 in
order to incite protesters towards
suspecting and also killing innocent
civilians the military resorted to using
agents provocateurs so first
in cases where the strike committees
captured alleged criminals the state
agents
they infiltrated the public
interrogations and also provoked public
anger
which drove people to behave those that
they had arrested without concrete
evidence of crimes
and
one yangon resident described such
intervention here
and many other witnesses they also
corroborate the presence of state agents
in inciting brutal punishment of
captured criminal suspects in similar
cases as well and this is just
one one of those quotes
and immediately afterwards the
government they also arrested the strike
committee members to whom uh whom its
asians had earlier provoked
and um finally
uh the state agents at the same time
they photographed and filmed these
incidents of public executions and
broadcast them as evidence of the
uprising's anarchy
the state's next strategy was drugging
protesters and strike committee members
in order to make them vulnerable to
manipulation into publicly executing
innocent people
not only did they drug people but in
many cases they even arrested these
protesters later on in order to
cover up like their involvement as well
um so
here is a quote
by a resident in the town of malamian
who recalls how one of her acquaintances
also fell into this trap
and
last but not least
state agents they provided guns and
homemade weapons to neighborhood strike
committees in order to facilitate
violent attacks and later on
also arrested or executed these people
as well so a former student activist
here in 1988 describes how her adoptive
father was framed here
um and
another
student union member in yemen
in the town of yenanjong
name is mumman wood
he also met the same fate so at the
height of the 48th the police in
yeongjung offered to work with the
student union to take care of the city
security
the police chief himself also gave mamma
woon a gun in the name of equipping the
student union to provide law and order
and mammon would as a result was later
accused of stealing this gun and also
was jailed for two years
so overall right like um um i just
wanted to review um here in terms of the
um
two different types of strategies
strategy combinations
that the military they employed in 1988
versus in 2007 right so in 2007 whereas
most of the strategies that focus on
framing protesters for
violence uh towards civilians um in 1988
um there was also they they complemented
these types of strategies
with the incitement to toward uh
mob violence um against uh
the innocent civilians as well
uh
and you know these these state in terms
of the effect of these types of
strategies on the public perception of
the protest
um they these strategies they made local
residents consider
every protesters a potential threat
right um even in cases where people
suspected that the government you know
like had
a role to play in these types of
incidents
um and they suspected the covert
operation by the government but many of
the people that i
interviewed they still became wary of
the asian provocateurs hiding among
protest groups as as you can see in this
quote here
and uh moreover in 1988 very like um
many people were also legitimately
frightened by the killings and
beheadings of civilians
a resident of south oklahoma township in
1988 and this quote here
shares her traumatic memory
and an interviewee who
actually also
lived
outside of yangon in 1988 also knew
about these um these killings like via
the state tv uh broadcast
and uh and and therefore um you know he
himself was also negatively affected by
this type of news as well
so
therefore as you can see
people in general did perceive a certain
level of threat
from the protesters and from the
dissidents
and um depending on the level of threat
perception as well as depending on
their um the the um members of the
public their
social
and gender expectations
what i find is that these protest
observers they either passively avoided
protest events
or withdrew their support to protesters
or actively block protest marches and
confronted protesters
so um
so first of all regarding the passive
facility
so what i find is that since the direct
confrontation
you know was considered was perceived by
uh many people as a high risk act where
people might have to engage in uh
violently with the protesters right that
could result in casualties most people
tended to stay away from crowds that
were alleged to
harbor supporters or criminals
or rioters and as a result in 1988
people would rather say sit at home
and guard their own places instead of
going outside to support protests and
similarly since the beginning of the
2007 events
due to fear of criminals mixing among
the protesters
many interviewees they also stayed away
from protest areas and avoided traveling
out of town as it was considered unsafe
uh moreover right so uh regarding active
facility according to um oh sorry before
i go to that so according to my
interviewees most of the bystanders they
also they um
they also did not intervene they chose
not to intervene when the military or
the police dealt with the accused uh
quote-unquote rioters or criminals um in
1988 or in 2007 um
as people consider these protesters as
threat
they became reluctant to support or help
during government crackdowns
and furthermore right like in the latter
days of of the foreign uprising uh due
to a high level of traffic perception uh
adult men from various neighborhoods
they also became uh morally obliged to
secure their own streets and confront
protesters and in a matter of days
yangon transformed from a friendly and
peaceful community into a hostile
environment for public demonstrations
as many of my interviewees recall here
and the
the these type of neighborhood
self-organized vigilante teams they also
armed themselves
and blocked uh protests
from passing through their areas in
order to avoid risk of violence directed
at their families and of their neighbors
as you can see in these two quotes
and due to these forms of
active hostility
it has a direct effect on the
pro-democracy movement itself a
and here in this court you can see a
former student activist
describing the difficulty of carrying
out public protests at the time due to
the neighborhood vigilantes like
blocking the streets
and uh
moreover i am another
former student activists
also commented on how
the state strategies they generated a
widespread distinction and also led to
separation between the the general
public
and the student protesters
which
according to him was one of the main
reasons why
the protests failed
in the end in 1988
right
so um in the next section um you know uh
i would like to go through the
alternative explanations for for these
phenomenons as i'm sure that
some of you might also have those
questions in mind as well
so uh first of all
uh
my the first alternative explanation uh
is uh regarding the government threat uh
sorry uh regarding government reward
right so uh were the disruptive and
hostile civilians like mostly
people who received
rewards from the regime
so from many of the existing studies as
well as reports we know that
statehide violent agents have
been involved in attacking pro-democracy
activists in myanmar right so for
example a student activist in 1988
among my interviewees also remembers how
the government appointed administrators
in his own word
who clearly were regime supporters
requested informers to come watch and
arrest activists in his area and in 2007
another witness who lived near the
protest site also recalled how the state
hired thugs came to crush the protesters
as well
and other
studies have also shown right like based
on the
information and evidence that they have
gathered uh they have also described how
in some cases of the civilian disruption
in 1988 that people were hired and
trained to attack and kill the
protesters
so however since the burmese
dictatorship since they limited the
number of the reward recipients and the
hyde agents even though these people
were involved in anti-protester violence
they did not make up the majority of the
cases and indeed like most of the
civilians um who disrupted the activists
or who became hostile toward the
activists as i find from my own
interview data um they did not receive
rewards um prior to the actions and in
fact like most of the
urban burmese population at that time uh
were burdened uh you know like by poor
public services and lack of social
security which made them become
dissatisfied with the regime at the
first place and therefore civilian
hostility in my case studies was mostly
not motivated by the regimes we were
and and how about the government's
threat right so were members of the
general public threatened to cooperate
with the government crackdown
leading to hostility and disruption
toward the protesters
um even though the security forces they
didn't threaten civilians um you know in
in
in terms of uh
uh sorry even though the security forces
they they did threaten the civilians i i
find that actually this did not have any
significant effect in terms of the
civilian hostility
in the cases of 1988 and 2007
events so first of all people might have
been threatened to stay away from
protest sites or not to support the
protests
but there was no evidence that they were
forced to actively confront or to
actively block the activists and second
you know
among the
people that i have interviewed um if
they themselves have experienced like
these types of threat like from the
military from the soldiers from the
police uh telling them requesting them
right like uh not to go out to to
support or to watch the protest event um
they they they would detail those kinds
of experiences um you know very clearly
right but at the same time like as they
were talking about that um they they
also expressed right like how their own
traumatic
you know impression of um the um rumors
about violence or the actual violence
that the protesters and the dissidents
had carried out also had um you know
made them become
more reluctant as well as more
feeling more threatened and also um
becoming more hostile toward these these
protesters as well so so so those two
things they could also happen at the
same time and and the interviewees they
they they were readily shared about
those types of experiences
and secondly like many interviewees they
also detailed how their neighbors and
their mosque
pagodas and churches even refused to
comply with the government's order and
many of them also offer shelter to the
movement participants
so um therefore the government press
were mostly irrelevant in these case
studies in terms of shaping the civilian
hostility and destruction
um and what about in terms of ethnic
difference right so in this case as
farmer buddhists were thought to make up
i mean they make up the vast majority of
the population and therefore they also
were thought to make out the vast
majority of the urban pro-democracy
protesters so in this case uh were
non-vermont like more likely to engage
in civilian uh in in disruption and in
hostilities toward the protesters
um so uh based on you know the the data
that i have collected um there are cases
where the existing ethnic tension um
hindered a non-bombard from supporting
the activists so for instance a karen
man
who is an ethnic minority living in
yangon in 2007 um he shared how his um
current neighborhood was not really
bothered much by this big repression of
the ethnic vermont monks and protesters
and this is because many minority i
think my population say they
they regarded by my people
as their oppressors for decades
therefore the protesters ethnicity
background also made them appear as
quote-unquote villains
to these minority neighborhoods and also
deter the um support from these
neighborhoods to with the protesters um
as well
um however like even though you know
like um this is uh one instance that i
have found like during my interview
but other evidence that i have um you
know like collected uh
via my field work have also shown that
the um
observers who were by my buddies
themselves right they um
were also engaged right like in these
forms of hostility and this form of
disruption um due to the impression like
of the protesters as a
dangerous a physical threat to their
neighborhood
so um so um overall right i i also think
that these these
findings from from my research and they
also have um relevant implications for
the current case of the post crew
myanmar in 2021 as well
um so from most of the existing reports
and studies that we have seen
the number they uh recently they have
also used very some similar types of uh
strategies uh both uh you know employing
public as well as covert propaganda to
manipulate narratives about protesters
and frame them as criminals in order to
turn public opinion against the
resistance and in favor of safe
oppression right so with regard to
public propaganda to frame protesters of
conducting violence against public
interest
for for example
the military control miyagi tv they
recently aired an interview with a monk
who claimed that nld supporters burned
down a village and also compare nld to
the taliban right
which is essentially associating nld
members with criminal images that would
resonate with the majority of burmese
buddhist audience many of whom might
also have discrimination against people
of muslim heritage and in a similar vein
um in just last june the state media
report they also accused the
national unity government and other
resistance forces of quote
communicating with international
terrorists and the arsa the rohingya
muslim insurgent group to grasp the
state power by force unquote
moreover the military-controlled
ministry of information they have also
started publishing books that accuse the
anti-regime movement of being a quote
unquote a revolution to bring back vote
cheaters
the military also disseminated
newsletters that label protests as
rioters as anarchic and you know as
sabotage activities so very similar
types of rhetoric that you know we have
witnessed um back in uh you know before
2010 as well
on top of that um regarding uh with
covert strategies um the tamara recently
they has also have uh mastered um in
their social media repertoire and and
therefore they spread online this
information under the guise of ordinary
observers in order to
build an echo chamber right affect echo
chamber reinforcing their official
propaganda and numerous reports have
found that state coordinator chose to
have engaged in disseminating this
information about anti-government
protesters with false accusations and
manipulated images of violence so for
example as you can see you know in these
kinds of images on social media
the pro-military social media accounts
they claimed that security forces did
not kill protesters but it was a third
party that was responsible uh referring
to other protesters and other members of
resistance different resistance forces
and some protesters were even falsely
accused of killing the police or raping
women
other pro-military accounts
have also accused anti-regime dissidents
who have turned to violent methods of
being manipulated by foreign forces and
islamist groups like the isis and the
taliban and even suggest without
evidence that muslims were behind the
attacks
yeah so
not only in the post school myanmar in
2020 we would also find uh you know very
similar and familiar types of strategies
in other cases
beyond myanmar as well
so um based on my own you know survey of
the existing literature as well as
existing reports um on uh the uh state
suppression of the civic space um other
state leaders have also combined you
know like um these um strategies either
in terms of framing protesters for
violence or inciting protesters to work
uh you know committing violence um
toward the civilian targets um they will
also come uh buying these type of
strategies in order to provoke um
anti-protesters hostility right so in
this table you can find some of those
examples where state leaders across asia
europe and africa and the americas have
simultaneously spread this information
both publicly and covertly and going one
step further like toward a number of
targeted movements the political elites
um in the us uk and mexico
not only actively vilified the
protesters but also
employed asian provocateurs who urged
funded and also armed uh protesters
violent sabotage as well
um so uh so uh therefore right like as
we can see
these very familiar strategies
being employed in
different regime political regime
context and also in the current context
of myanmar
i hope that the
findings
that
i have presented today like based on my
research on the case of myanmar between
1988 and 2010 could also offer some
insights
and also some
[Music]
relevant perspectives to help us
understand the
implications of these uh strategies um
in the case of the post myanma and in
other cases around the world as well
so um yeah so so in conclusion
um by conducting uh the analysis like on
the emergence of civilian hostility
toward pro-democracy protests in the
myanmar context um you know i
would say that you know like my
my research right now it complements the
current literature um on the 1988 and
the 2007 events by presenting a more
comprehensive picture of an important
yet largely neglected component of the
state suppression strategies toward
descent and by illustrating these
mechanisms i also hope to contribute to
the burma studies literature
by refuting the claims that the mob
participants
in 1988 were
exceptional or um were
um
a particularly um quote unquote savage
right like in any sense um they did not
automatically become violence when there
were no functioning state institutions
and as the militar as the myanmar
and some scholars have claimed um on the
other hand like most people they were
disgusted and they were traumatized by
the public executions of the
um criminal suspects
and the strike committee members
moreover they were mainly under the
influence of the state incitement when
they engaged in such types of collective
assaults
and my studies also makes contributions
here toward the social movement and the
authoritarianism literature as well so
first it highlights the authoritative
regime's deceptive tactics as an
important part in their toolbox to
manufacture a hostile environment for
contentious actors and in order to
suppress the scent and this would also
deepen our understanding of mechanisms
for authoritarian survival like
especially during critical times of
public uprisings beyond the conventional
models of cooperation and repression
um and i propose that this this finding
can serve as a unique and valuable
evidence for advocacy against the
suppression of civic space as human
rights activists and journalists they
might expose the
covert strategies and raise awareness
among the general public and
international community in order to
deter the state leaders from employing
these tactics in the future
and in another part of my dissertation i
also find that activists might also
neutralize these state strategies by
actively debunking the state
disinformation um you know by
staying vigilant to the incitement to to
violence and also by coordinating um uh
collective support like from
the general public toward protesters and
the resulting support and protection by
these civilians in contrast to hostile
disruption would increase the activist
survival and commitment to the movement
and foster movement resilience in the
face of um
in the face of state repression as well
however due to the constraint of the
presentation
time today so i think um i would
probably um if you're interested in
reading more about that part of my
research i
i can also share with you uh my my
dissertation a copy of my dissertation
as well so thank you very much for
listening
thank you van
this is a really fascinating talk
i'm going to open it up to discussion
now
i will moderate i have some questions of
my own but i'll reserve them until we
get a few from people in the audience
here
so
if you can raise your hand using the the
the chat function not the chat function
but the reaction function
then i'll see your hand go up but i see
that we have two questions
in the chat already
so let me ask um i'll start with the
lisa brewton
if you don't mind just asking your
question or if you prefer me to read it
i will read it um and then there's
another question
um from jacksonvaughn and then while we
take these questions anyone else put
your hand up and i will uh find the time
to call on you
i am happy to read my i'm happy to ask
you directly i thank you for that
presentation
um i wonder if you could um talk a
little bit about what you see in terms
of differences of citizen responses
today compared to those who you
um
today to today's state violence and
state
dis and misinformation compared to
what your respondents told you about the
situation in uh
uh 88 and 2007.
um yes um thank you very much for your
question um lisa so um
i think you know like i'm so um just uh
in terms of the the work that i'm
currently conducting like uh uh
regarding the current situation um um so
i have not really i've been able to
conduct any kind of systematic study
like where i could interview or survey
people on the ground
most of
the work that i have been doing right
now is in terms of
surveying the landscape of social media
content in myanmar
and
they're therefore like based on that
type of content um i think that there
could also be in a way
findings that
might not be uh might not be comparable
to the situation before 2010 right so uh
what i find in terms of the social media
content that i thought that i have
online so far in terms of the
way where i study the um top uh most
viral content um on on facebook in
myanmar during the past few months uh
most of the content um uh and in terms
of on online users in vienna they have
been very supportive like of the
uh poor democracy content and at the
same time they have also been very
actively
um actively exposing
incidents of state violence online and
at the same time regarding the state
missing this information um you know i
show some of the examples right in in
the presentation in terms of you know um
alleging
an idea being associated with taliban or
isis or arsa those types of
misunderstanding are there and they
exist however among the most viral
contents they do not make it to the top
uh which uh could also indicate that
most of the on online users and you know
they um
have been um somewhat right maybe become
more vigilant against these types of uh
missing disinformation um and um you
know and and and um it could also
indicate that by being online whether it
be being on social media uh this
particular group of population they have
also been more exposed to alternative
and um discourse right
from people that support the resistance
itself right so
which could also affect you know the way
that they view the state disinformation
as well however i i could not speak for
you know in terms of the
population who might not be online right
who might not be exposed to to to these
types of um alternative discourses and
also these efforts by
activists to debunk the state
disinformation on social media so for
people that um you know like have mostly
consumed content via you know
traditional form of like tv or radio or
newspaper um you know um i i
thought that that is a part that that
i think
could have very different types of
findings um yeah but i've yet been able
to to look into that yeah yeah
thanks
thank you very much new do you want to
ask your question now
yeah thank you uh eric
and thank you evan for a great
presentation i really enjoyed it and um
i as you right now find your research
super interesting and relevant um so my
question have to do with trying to
understand um the logic of suppression
or the logic of governance of the state
in reaction in relation to the to
societal opposition
and the question that i and what i'm not
clear about um
is
when and why
would a state use this strategy
in other words while we know that and we
can see as you show in your last slide
this the combination of this sort of
framing trying to de-legitimize the
opposition versus the combination of
also strategic incite violence
also to delegitimize uh opposition and
participants these elements can be found
in many other cases right in many
incidents both within
myanmar and outside myanmar
so the question is when when would even
the minimum government when is the
myanmar government decide to apply the
strategy and when it does not and then
why do some
states do and why some they do not
um and that that's something that i find
i would love to hear your thoughts on
that thanks so much
yeah thank you for the great question
you so so first of all um regarding you
know like the question of um um
the decision by a state when when not to
use a certain type of strategy um i i i
i don't have much confidence there too
to be honest i i would say that i know
when they they do apply these types of
strategies uh but but uh
you know in terms of why they decide to
do so i i can only have guesses
um i think that uh particularly you know
like you know um in in in the case of um
uh the uh in the case of myanmar before
2010 right um we could also find that
there there could be
different reasons so so first of all
um during 1988 like we have a um
different uh
general at the top of the government
versus in 2010 right so um they could
have very different types of strategies
to suppress descent
um and and and and
furthermore it uh you know um it could
also be the case that as um many people
would also know the scale of the uh
protests in 1988 was uh much wider and
much more you know encompassing of the
different groups of the population so
the traditional or more conventional uh
more conservative
type of strategies right to repress or
to suppress dissent and um you know
that they have tried might have not
worked as much as they had hoped and so
therefore they added this additional
step right but but at the same time i
think that's um you know we also find
that uh
the these exact strategies um probably
not but very similar strategies um they
have also been employed um recently um
you know like um after um the uh by the
uh myanmar military after the coup in
february as well um due to the fact that
a lot of the people that are you know on
the um advisory council to the military
right now they were also related to the
uh due to the new wind family or you
know like to uh the the
previous leaders of the previous regime
so so i think that there there could be
different types of factors right um
regarding you know the uh the the the
uh i would say you know like the the the
style um of suppression of each of the
leaders and at the same time it could
also be the situation right um that they
they find themselves under as well
um and and regarding you know like um
thinking uh broader uh more more broadly
in terms of you know beyond me and mine
in other cases in other states and so
first of all what i would like to say is
that um the data that i have right now
it might also be incomplete right
especially regarding the covert
strategies we only know them when we
have like these types of information
being released to the public right so we
only for example in in the case um of
the the um uh us um cointelpro up
operation uh those who only know like
after we already had like a public
investigation into into these cases so
it could also be that the application of
these types of covert strategies are
much more widespread and and the pattern
could also look different from from what
we know now however
one thing that i think is is also um
a i
i think that could also offer maybe one
possible explanation for the variation
in terms of which states do or do not um
employ these types of strategies to
provoke public hostility um i i would
say that for um
certain states that are and in certain
regimes um that
are more willing to directly crack down
to directly repress um uh protest uh
you know without fear of
getting backlash from the public
population from the uh you know the
members of the public
they would find less need to to to to
employ these things um
more covert uh strategies yeah and so
that's just one possible explanation but
i'd love to discuss more if you have
other ideas
thanks i'm going to ask my question now
um
there's a little mystery that i'm
working with in my head as i'm listening
to this talk
it's not your research it's just a
question that i can't stop having
and it's about the methodology a little
bit um where you can conduct interviews
with people and the people will say
look i know that the state was sending
agent provocateur or i know the state
was inciting violence i know x was
happening right like they are able in
recounting and telling the story
um to distinguish
the state's kind of provocations all the
elements that you describe all the
strategies and styles that you've
described right like people can figure
it out right they're not fooled by it
right
at the same time
um
it seems to work in a weird way too
right like there's moments like in the
heat of the moment it seems
almost that people
yeah they do get kind of
worried about those protesters and
maybe there's a seed of doubt or a
concern that they don't know who's
violent or not or something like that
right and so i guess my question is
how do we develop a kind of theory about
the way in which people both know that
the state is or the junta is doing this
machination and trickery and deception
right
but at the same time
they then feel themselves compelled
almost to be a little bit worried about
those protesters even though they know
the protesters actually may politically
be on the same side as them actually
right in some sense right
um have you thought a little bit about
how to reconcile that kind of conundrum
a little bit and how is it that people
when they recount the story
can actually say oh yeah i was a state
provocateur but then when you look at
your data there's lots of people who
don't realize that it seems right
um yeah so so i think to to answer that
question i think like uh first of all i
think that there are two parts here like
in terms of the what the state
provocateurs what what what they did
right
um and um these uh and and also secondly
in terms of you know um these types of
actions um you know what kind of effect
they have like on the protesters and on
on the kind of protest observers
um i would say that in terms of like
recounting these types of experiences um
like people
could have pinpointed rightly in terms
of hey like um uh these are um instances
where i find it like so strange that you
know you would have like these people
uh who would come and provoke violence
but at the same time like
later on you find them like being ready
with a camera and then they are also the
one who would like report uh you know
like to the statue to arrest these types
of people so that that's something that
people can piece together
i do not think that is very much in
terms of like being a cognitive
dissonance um as you know uh people also
find that they they themselves are
are worried that uh sure right so um we
might believe the protesters however
um
you know how many people out there are
real protesters and how many people out
there they are the state eight
asians and um that is something that you
know like that they do not know and and
exactly like i think that this this is a
type of strategy that i also find in a
way um
has been um
uh accountable right like for um uh uh
in in
accountable for creating um or um or or
increasing a uh
distrust among society and and this um
overall this this um level of uh
distrust right like uh when um
when it increases then then people would
also find um themselves to be less
willing to to have you know like um
strangers interacting with them or you
know to to supporting um these these
people that that they don't know where
they come from what they have done or
what they might do to to their
neighborhoods as well so this is
something um that's um you know where
even when people are aware of the
safe strategies um doesn't mean that the
strategies won't have effect and um this
could also be something that the the
regime themselves they they might have
counted on as well
yeah
in some sense the strategy
plants so much uncertainty
that it creates it just makes it
impossible to
ever feel secure in who you know is and
who is who and what's going on right i
mean in some sense it's kind of similar
to this fake news
phenomenon like once you plant the idea
that there may be fake news you can't
yeah yeah yeah i think that's that's
that's exactly the the case there
um yeah and then like they like people
um
in terms of at least in terms of people
that i have interviewed
uh
they they also find that uh you know
even if the protesters themselves they
they did not um
originally plan to conduct violence
against innocent civilians but they are
susceptible toward provocation to these
types of violence so um this is
something that also
made you know a very um
a i would say um
uh made the the the civilian observers
that the they have a very high level of
um threat perception um you know
regarding how they think about these
these protesters yeah
thanks tweet do you want to ask your
question now
okay thank you
uh
of course i was impressed when i got the
news about
the presenter is one john i see
vietnamese nc during research in perma
and that's very impressive so
uh and thank you father for an
interesting uh talk um i am not
interested online political science
but i'm interested in
the demographic crap that you saw like i
see them there were more
more
male men than women
in the process and the the
representation like the modern
the rest is like uh in 2007 is the more
man
than than women compared to
98 88 and um lastly
in the protest uh unless some sometimes
i go like some some like one or two
years
last year sometime i i heard from the
news i'm not sure is that the fake news
about the protesters of the burma women
they they protest they use underwear and
they hang out underwear women underwear
on the street
because they use the tradition that
demand don't cross
the
under the underwear of the women
so that to me that's that's much and
that's fun and smart
it also reminds me about
vietnamese women movement during the war
you may know about the saying very
famously in vietnam
and they don't care it's a vietnamese
movement during the war between the
american war in vietnam
so uh if you have vietnamese you are
doing research in in burma so how
how you see the
the the burma women now
compared to the burmese women
to me like i see because i'm doing
research and it's related to history via
women history so i see like
during the war
women like vietnamese women we
like germany
but now we lose that that motivation
that we lose that effort now
women
we more like
accept what we have compared to before
so and in burma i'm so i see we see now
like more male than female do being
professor
like
in your life later or in your research
can you have more explanation on that
because i see you your demographics cry
but i didn't see you explain why
thank you sure sure yeah yeah i would
say thank you so much for for your
questions um so uh i i think that is
also like a really great question too
because um i think that you had uh
probably like a really sharp observation
there um because um also according to my
own observation right and also based on
studying the existing reports and
documentations of the protest events
like before 2010 um most of them despite
the fact we have the leader of the main
opposition party being women but uh most
of the uh protest events at that time
they uh were participated by men and and
they they also were also led by by men
as well
um i also had uh so during my field work
i also had to intentionally i asked uh
you know my internal tutors to help me
to recruit uh female in interviewees
people who themselves will also
experience and either observed or
directly participate
in these these types of protests um and
uh at the same time what we find is that
these these types of like um rhetorics
like these uh feminist um rhetorics and
and these feminist demands that we see
um in 2020 these are the things that i
did not find at all in terms of the most
popular demands or rhetorics like before
2010 so um in a way like to me it was um
a um a very encouraging side and and i
really hoped to see
more of that type of development um as
well
um yeah yeah i hope that that answer
your your question somewhat
yeah
um
thank you van and thank you tweep and
everyone else for these great questions
um we're at the end of the formal time
for our q a um what i will do at this
moment is stop the recording and then
i'll leave the the zoom open for
informal chit chat after this point but
please join me everyone for a moment to
thank
dr van jon for this fantastic talk so
thank you very much
thank you everybody for attending for
yeah
very interesting questions too